So now that we've got an understanding of the high level networking setup of Unreal,
we now need to look at the main gameplay systems that interact within the networked
structure of our game.
So we already know that the game mode is on the server only, but where is everything
else?
We've got a number of gameplay critical classes and as you'd expect they only exist
in certain places.
So first we've got the game mode as we know it only exists on the server.
Next is the game state and this exists on both server and client.
The game instance exists on both server and client but it's not replicated, so each connection
will have their own unique instance as well as the server.
The player controller exists on the server and the owning client but never the remote
clients.
Pawns and characters exist on the server and the client and are replicated down.
Next we've got the player state and this is the same as the game state, it exists
on the server and is replicated down appropriately.
Finally we've got the HUD and any associated user widgets, these are all client only.